first and foremost happy pride it is
pride month it is the best month of the
year
listen
although it is pride month and i am
happy
i'm also quite sad that this series is
coming to an end as millions around the
world are as well michael you know
listen this has been quite a
journey for you and you called it the
journey of your life on instagram
how are you feeling knowing that a show
that has been so impactful to millions
of people around the world is coming to
an end and essentially you're saying
bye-bye to this character
yeah i mean i honestly it's one of those
things where it's like
it's going to take a lot to top this
this was an incredible project and
has really changed my life in so many
ways like
i i'm just so grateful for it and so
grateful for the people that i've met
throughout this whole process
george is incredible and it was awesome
to work with him and i feel like i've
learned so much from george and this
amazing cast and crew so i don't know i
i don't i don't it's going to take a lot
to top this and i don't think anything
will top it for a very long time
you're probably right about that and you
know what like you're still in it right
now but maybe once you
separate yourself from this project for
a bit of time it's gonna really sink in
how impactful this was george listen it
is incredible to be on a series that
millions of people around the world
watch and enjoy
but in my mind i think it's even better
to be on a series that is
changing lives and it really has and it
is changing you know perceptions too so
for you
what has been the best part of being
part of a series like love victor
massively yeah no i think you hit the
nail on the head there like that is a
huge part of it
um
like it's you know as an actor it's like
it's hard to book an acting job and then
when you book one as special as this
that really
makes an impact and connects with people
and you know
like we hear from i've been hearing so
much from um like lgbtq youth who you
know they feel seen and they they love
the show and they really connect to it
it's really beautiful it's amazing and
then to hear from people like slightly
older people who say oh i wish i had a
show like this growing up like it's yeah
you know it's it's amazing like it makes
me so proud of the show and it just like
fills me with joy that i was able to be
a part of that
yeah you hit the nail on the head right
there yourself because i am much older
than both of you and i did not grow up
with a show like this so to have this
representation on television and it just
be such a
beautiful series is so important i hope
you both really do walk away from this
project knowing how much it really has
meant to people around the world michael
when you read the final script the last
episode for the very first time tell me
what went through your head because
we're not gonna spoil things here but
what went through your head
geez it was it was very emotional you
know what i mean like i i'm so
passionate about this project and i've
been so passionate about it and
it's crazy coming to an end you know
what i mean when i i was like
you know like wow i don't know how
people are going to take this i didn't
know how else to take it because it was
just like so much
of my passion and so much of my love
like just like this chapter coming to a
close and
i don't know i i now looking back i
think that people are really gonna love
this ending and i think that people are
really going to
to be able to trust the the characters
are going to make the right decisions
with the rest of their lives and
do the right things without the audience
watching them you know
yeah it feels it feels like a really
right ending it's very full circle and
it just it felt so right and um i think
people are going to be happy with the
ending i do and we felt very very happy
with it too when we were there filming
it
i think people will be happy with it
listen i can only imagine after you
spend so much time on set together and
just as a cast that when something like
this ends it's incredibly emotional
you've said it was so i'm curious we
want some tea here at et canada who was
the one who could not hold back the
emotions with the word were there
waterfalls who was the messiest and most
emotional on the final day definitely
this guy
i'd say
oh anthony
like i i've seen i feel like i've seen
you emotional before but i hadn't really
seen her emotionally i suppose end of
season too he was quite emotional as
well yeah uh i i'd also say like bella
and ava everyone was crying everything
was like this massive like group hug
everybody was yeah everybody had tears
and
it was very it was very like we were
just like grieving you know together
yeah
well like i mentioned it is pride month
so i'm wondering if i could get a quick
little message from both of you just to
the queer youth out there uh if there's
anything you would like to say to them
i'll start with you michael
definitely i i mean i'd say that
our show is all about bravery and it's
about embracing who you are
and being brave enough to to pursue your
life the way you want to whether it's
loving who you want like loving who you
want to love and embracing your gender
identity
these are all things that you should be
able to do and no matter who stops you
there is a community out there that will
accept you
so
don't don't let anybody stop you don't
let anybody tell you what how to live
your life because there is a huge group
of people that will accept you for the
way you are and
i know we would and so
you know you just gotta do yourself
first
i love that so much anything from you
george yeah i mean pride is all about
like celebrating who you are embracing
who you are embracing that community and
yeah if times are hard right now um just
know that there are people out there
that will love you for who you are and i
think that's just just stay strong in
that
i love that so much listen it's been a
total pleasure talking to both of you
i'm sure we'll catch up eventually on
other projects but again congratulations
and i really hope you do know that
making a series like this is incredibly
powerful and i just want to say thank
you for it so again congrats season
three is it awesome and uh we'll talk
soon thanks alice
oh hey there if you want more lgbtq news
and exclusive interviews click subscribe
or watch these videos